Hello friends and members of our Sum TV
family. Welcome to I'd like to know, our
Bible question and answer program. You
send in Bible questions and we give you
Bible-based answers from the word of
God. My name is CA Murray. To my right
is Pastor Steven Boore. To my left is
Pastor David Salazar. and gentlemen, we
greet you. Always good to study the word
of God with you both.
>> Amen.
>> And uh good to have you here, our
viewing audience. Should you want to get
in on the fun, send your question in, we
ask you to send that question to
tvsumsv.org.
That's tv.sumtv.org.
And we will get to your question just as
soon as we can. We have a lot of
questions which is a good problem to
have and we thank you in advance for
that. May we ask that when you send in
your question please give us your name.
You can give us just the first name if
you wish but let us know where you are
writing from. Can be the country, can be
the state, can be the province. Just
give us some idea where you're writing
from so that we kind of know what our
footprint is and that we are touching uh
the family of God where they itch and we
are doing what God has called us to do.
We thank you for that. in advance.
Pastor Bora, would you be kind enough to
pray as we begin our program for the
day?
>> Father in heaven, as we begin our
program, we ask for the presence of your
spirit, enlighten our minds, give us
words to speak and bless those who are
watching the program. We pray in Jesus
name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. And amen. Our first question today
comes to us from Tanzania. Uh some say
Tanzania. Uh Matias is writing
somewhat lengthy so we'll uh try to read
as quick as we can. I hope you are doing
well. I have a Bible and spirit of
prophecy question that I would like to
understand more clearly. What does the
phrase present truth or truth for this
time mean especially in the writings of
Ellen G. White? For example, in
Testimonies for the Church, volume 5,
pages 364,
she wrote, "My sister, dare you
disregard these plans and positive
directions? As a child of God, a subject
of Christ's kingdom, the purchase of his
blood, how can you connect yourself with
one who does not acknowledge his
claims?" that his is of course God's
claims or Christ's claims who is not
controlled by his spirit. The commands I
have quoted are not the word of man but
of God.
Though the companion of your choice were
in all other respects worthy uh which he
is not yet he is not acceptable. He has
not accepted rather the truth for this
time. He is an unbeliever and you are
forbidden of heaven to unite yourself
with him. You cannot without peril of
your soul to your soul rather disregard
this divine injunction.
I would be grateful if you could explain
what Ellen White meant by the truth for
this time in this context and more
generally in her writings. Thank you
very much for your time and guidance.
May God continue to bless your ministry.
M
>> so he wants to know about the term
present truth and the truth for this
time. Actually the second explains the
first present [snorts] truth is the
truth for this time.
>> Right?
>> Present truth is always truth that is
applicable to the children of God to the
world for the particular time it is
given and in which that and the context
in which it finds itself. Um, this
ministry, Pastor Boore, was established
to give these last generations of the
Seventh Adventist Church present truth
for this time,
>> right?
>> Uh, basically, uh, several years ago,
actually, right after we started our
ministry, I wrote a book and the name of
the book is a worship at Satan's Throne.
And in this book I address the issue of
present truth. Uh what is present truth?
Present truth is the truth that is
relevant for that particular moment.
>> Exactly.
>> For example, the present truth when
Christ was born was sung by the angels.
>> And was given by the wise men.
>> The Messiah has been born. That was
present truth. Mhm.
>> When Jesus began his ministry, John the
Baptist brought present truth. The
Messiah is about to begin his ministry.
>> And then when Jesus died on the cross,
the triumphal entry into Jerusalem, the
king is coming sitting on a donkey.
Royalty.
>> Mhm.
>> When Pentecost came, there's a present
truth. Jesus is going into the holy
place. That was present truth.
>> Yes.
What was the present truth in 1844?
>> The sanctuary shall be cleansed
>> of course.
>> And we are living in that time.
>> So every truth
related to what Jesus is doing in the
most holy place is present truth. Now
that doesn't mean that uh the other
truths are not essential. Got
>> because each truth builds on upon the
previous one, right?
>> You know the birth of Jesus is
important. Uh the ministry of Jesus is
important. His death is important. His
resurrection is important. His
intercession is important. His uh work
as judge is important. The aazil uh is
important.
>> All of the works are important. But what
is occurring right at the moment
>> that is present truth. You know, I wrote
in this book um a chapter titled
Alarming Current Trends
>> and basically I showed that Adventist
theology has shifted
from the sanctuary as the governing
principle.
>> Yeah.
>> To righteousness by faith as the
governing principle. We want to go back
to the time of the reformers.
>> Exactly.
>> Well, the reformers did not have present
truth. They did not have the Sabbath.
They did not have the right view of
death. They did not have the three
angels messages etc.
>> So their [clears throat] truth was truth
for that time. But we need to look at
the truth that they brought forth in the
light of what Jesus is doing now in the
sanctuary. True.
>> If I could just read Ellen White um
in uh I think this is the book early
writings page 63. She defined what
present truth is.
>> She said, "There are many precious
truths contained in the word of God. But
it is present truth that the flock needs
now."
>> Amen.
>> I have seen the danger of the messengers
running off from the important points of
present truth to dwell upon subjects
that are not calculated to unite the
flock and sanctify the soul.
>> Satan will here take every possible
advantage to injure the cause. Yes.
>> And now she's going to define what
present truth is. But such subjects as
the sanctuary,
>> in connection with the 2300 days,
>> the commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus are perfectly calculated to
explain the past advent movement and
show what our present position is,
establish the faith of the doubting, and
give certainty to the glorious future.
These I have frequently seen were the
principal subjects on which the
messengers should dwell.
>> That's a succinct uh uh definition of
what it is. In other statements, she
mentions the Sabbath as present truth.
>> She mentions the state of the dead as
present truth. She mentions the judgment
as present truth.
Everything that revolves around the most
holy place is present truth.
>> And of course, when the loudcry comes
and the latter rain is poured out,
>> then that will be present truth, but
it'll still be centered in the most holy
place of the sanctuary. It's the closing
work of the ministry of the heavenly
sanctuary. So, we need to get back to
our roots.
>> We we don't want to go back 350 years to
Luther. Now we need to understand
righteousness by faith.
>> We need to be be made righteous by
faith. No doubt about it.
>> But we have to move on from that.
>> Yes.
>> Because they had a limited
understanding. They didn't understand
the state of the dead. They did not
understand the Sabbath. They did not
understand health reform. Uh they did
not understand the judgment. And so and
so those are the subjects that we
contribute to the Christian world.
>> Amen.
>> Well said. You know the phrase present
truth
>> is actually found in the Bible itself.
In the second epistle of Peter, chapter
1 verse 12, he mentions this. First
Peter, I'm sorry, second Peter 1:12. For
this reason, I will not be negligent to
remind you always of these things,
though you know and are established in
the present truth.
>> And as you well said, pastor Board, the
truth, present truth that that a concept
is about what is relevant to the
experience of the church at the time in
which they are. Um so present truth for
us means something that demands a action
from our part to believe to be prepared
to be ready for his coming and if we
dwell on the precious truths that are in
the Bible like you know just
justification by faith and we only dwell
on that it's important but we neglect
the area of where we are in in the time
and where the Lord wants us to act upon
today. Now, present truth is not a
progressive revelation that contradicts
the scripture. It's not something new
that goes against already what
established in scripture. That's very
important. It's not new light that
nullifies the scriptures either. It's
not something that nullifies what
already has been established. It's not
also something that is of private or
speculative interpretation.
And it's not some sort of theology
that's just trendbased or, you know,
because popular. No, it's about
establishing the scriptures and
understanding
by the revelation of God what it is now
the the most important u understanding
or experience that God's people need to
have
>> what we should emphasize.
>> Exactly.
>> Exactly. So that's what you know I think
this will help our friend understand and
uh prison truth is uh again the most
important thing is to remember that God
has revealed to us his precious truths
for this time that has established our
church as the only church that really
understands the scripture from Genesis
to Revelation and can truly understand
what it means to be uh proclaiming this
gospel in these last days. Mhm.
>> One of the de facto realities as as um
far as present truth is concerned is
that it tends to bring balance to the
people of God. We as a a church if we
have one one
I shouldn't say problem or one reality
that we tend to swing one way or the
other. You know when when the uh early
church came in ly says we were law law.
So in 1888 we got some balance. We
brought Christ back to the center. Um
now we can one one of our challenges is
not to go so justification by faith that
we forget there is a law to be kept. You
know right there are commandments to be
obeyed. So present truth highlights the
truth from for that time but it tends to
keep the church dare I say on the
straight and narrow
>> heading in the right direction and not
veering to the right nor to to the left.
>> Amen.
Perhaps one last thing that I could say
about present truth that I think is
important to keep in mind just like in
the time of Noah you know what was the
present truth for that time the you know
the flood was coming
>> and I believe an aspect of present truth
that is and this is why there's such so
much resistance and the enemy wants to
put our eyes away from that is because
present truth will disrupt comfort will
challenge tradition
It requires a choice. Uh and and it it
really wants believers to
be transformed to to accept to grow
spiritually to become more like Christ.
And so it brings test. It brings trial.
It brings a a sense of figuring out
where your loyal where your loyalty is.
And so this is where um you know there's
expression that says that truth that
cause nothing usually tests nothing. Uh
and in this particular case you know
when you accept and you understand that
you're living in the last days that
we're having the time of you know God's
atonement going on the judgment has been
taking place. It's a time where you need
to put your your ducks in order in a way
you know to be in a harmony with God's
will to continually look upon Christ to
grow closer to the Lord to depend more
on God and less in yourself and this is
what the truth at times or the present
truth sometimes is not popular because a
lot of times the human heart wants to
feel comfortable in their condition
instead of being transformed. So present
truth will always kind of test you a
little bit whether you are wanting to
follow the Lord or not.
>> You know I have a statement here Ellen
White statement in this book that I
wrote. I would recommend everybody to
get a copy of this book.
>> Not because I wrote it but because it
really is uh present truth for this
time.
>> Um this is in signs of the times
December 27 1899. And I think way back
then she already had a clear vision.
Yeah. of things that were already
happening at that time in the church.
>> This is what she wrote. We are in danger
of making blunders in our missionary
effort.
>> In danger of failing to realize how
essential is the work of the Holy Spirit
upon the heart.
>> Wow.
>> A new order of things has come into the
ministry.
>> Yeah.
>> A new what?
>> Order of things.
>> A new order of things has come into the
ministry. There is a desire to pattern
after other churches.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And simplicity and humility are almost
unknown. This 1899,
she continues,
"Young ministers
who desire to be original
introduce new ideas and new plans for
labor. They open revival meetings and
call large numbers into the church. M
>> but when the excitement is over
>> where are the converted ones?
>> Yeah.
>> Repentance for sin is not felt.
>> The sinner is entreated to believe in
Christ and accept him without any regard
for his past life of sin and rebellion.
>> Yes.
>> And the heart is not broken.
>> Yeah.
>> There is no contrition of soul. The
professed professedly converted ones
have not fallen upon the rock Christ
Jesus. It's like she's writing in the
year 2026.
>> Precisely.
>> With the emphasis that takes place in
many of our churches these days. Uh
there's very little uh calling people to
repentance about the terrible nature of
sin and how wonderful is the grace of
Christ to take care of the issue of sin.
You know, there's just believe and
you're going to be saved and I'll
baptize you in water and know later on
you'll discover what you need to
believe. And Ellen White condemns that
>> in many places of her writings.
>> And while that happens, we're planting
tears in the church. I mean,
>> Jesus said that there will be tears in
the church, but that doesn't mean that
we have to plant them in the church.
[laughter]
>> Exactly.
>> Indeed. Again, it it brings us back to
balance. Brings us back to where we
should be. We've got time. I believe to
slip in one more question. This is from
Romy. And as the Lord liveth and as thy
soul liveth. We actually have a question
from California. Uh thank you Romy. Um
the question is asked, will both baby
and mature Christian believers be sealed
before the close of probation?
>> Well, the short answer is yes.
>> Yes. [laughter]
in the sense that you know remember the
there [clears throat] is a
you know prophetically speaking we see
that God will raise up the last uh call
to the world where many in Babylon are
called to come out of that and they
won't have a lot of time to grow into
mature Christians but they won't be um
as you said in another program pastor
they won't be a three-month baby born
you know
>> yeah They they have to they will be
babies but they have grown with with
with the knowledge they have received.
They have grown to the understanding of
the scriptures and they have by you know
by God's grace they have accepted the
truth of the Sabbath and that's what's
going to determine that they are part of
the being sealed in the and at the last
time I mean you know so so we understand
that when the closet happens the last
test to all the world is going to be
given to them whether they are faithful
to the Lord and accept his authority and
his ten commandments and the truths that
are found in the scriptures or they
accept the world and or a counterfeit of
Christianity enforcing Sunday as a day
of worship instead of Sabbath. So will
there be babies, you know, growth? I
mean, and natural Christians, believers,
yes, they will be.
>> You know, the bottom line is
that there are going to be 11th hour
workers.
>> Yes.
>> This is where the parable of Jesus fits
in.
>> Yeah. Mhm.
>> And Ellen White says that their zeal
will far surpass
>> Yes.
>> that of those that have been in the
church for a long time.
>> I personally believe
>> that and Ellen White corroborates this
that the growth experience of those who
enter the church during the loud cry
will be expedited.
>> In other words, they're going to grow
much faster because of the because of
the stress and because of what's
happening in the world. They're going to
grow in their faith much faster than
than us who are, you know,
>> hoh Christians. I I call them. Uh and uh
they will uh play a very important role
in finishing the work of God on this
earth.
>> Yeah. Well said. I I was thinking about
that 11th hour because my my dad came to
the Lord uh 30 days before he he passed
and my wife's father came in two weeks
before he passed. uh and at both
services the the the text that was
preached from was was uh coming in at
the 11th hour. But maturity in Christ is
not determined by time
>> or years. Yeah.
>> Per say or knowledge per se. Uh it's the
depth of surrender and obedience to to
what you know and what Christ has asked
you to do. Right. And so I agree with
you wholeheartedly, pastor, that there's
going to be some people who are going to
come in like gazels and leave some of
these slower animals behind, you know,
and and uh you know, she says people
going from place to place, their faces
lighted with the glory of God. So
there's going to be an energy in the
church that does not now exist. I have
said this before, I say it again. The
church is now Leodysian.
But sometime between this broadcast and
the second coming of Christ, the church
is going to move from Leodysian to one
that is under the the eegis of the
Lateran experience. So he's he's not
coming back for a Leodysian church. So
what we now are we will not then be and
it will be these last minute people
coming in with this energy and and grace
and glory who will uh uh
>> finish the work actually. And when the
shaking comes,
>> when Ellen White says it will come,
>> it will come.
>> Um, if you're if you're a lukewarm
Adventist,
you've got two options.
>> Grow cold like the world or warm up.
>> Warm up.
>> And the bottom line is that there are
many that are not members of the
Adventist church now that are not only
going to warm up, they're going to get
red hot. Red hot for the Lord. And uh of
course we long
>> for that day.
>> Yes.
>> When when uh the latter rain will fall.
But we have a preparation that needs to
be done.
>> We need to make a total commitment to
the Lord and then he'll pour out the
latter rain upon us.
>> That's where you know the the warning of
the Lord is um you know don't be
replaced by those who right now we
consider to be you know in the world. um
like happened to the Jews happened to
many of the of the Jews there who uh
they had the invitation of God to come
be part of his kingdom they rejected and
the harlots and the publicans they went
ahead of the religious leaders so that's
a warning to us and that's why God says
you know let no man take your crown
because it can happen somebody can take
your place if you're not connected with
God
>> you know gentlemen if you think that
North America is representative of the
world 7th day Adventist church, you you
have a certain myopia.
>> Those of you who've traveled outside the
church know the latter end is falling.
There are there are men and women who
are on fire for the Lord. That's
>> right.
>> There are people who will who who are
just going through many many things
gladly for the kingdom of God. When we
talk about latter rain, we tend to
think, well, we're talking about North
America. North America's got to catch
up. You know, North America is behind,
but there are places that are totally
surrendered, individuals who are totally
surrendered, and there are some in North
America also.
>> But, uh, as as a rule, as a general way
of looking at it, North America has some
problems that come from excess and
prosperity that the other parts of the
world simply do not have.
>> Uh, so uh, we're not talking about the
latter rain in North America. We're
talking about the latter rain in the
world, church. But now financial
prosperity
is not so great in North America. While
you look at the statistics and what's
happening,
>> you know, there's tremendous financial
struggles in many circles in the church.
Um so we need to focus on the mission
>> and not on the money.
>> Exactly.
>> And not on the numbers.
>> Amen.
>> God is the one that computes the
numbers. But uh we have no reason to
boast because
50 or 60 people were baptized in a
crusade. You know all the honor and the
glory
>> is for God.
>> Amen.
>> None for us.
>> And you know sometimes we we have this
triumphalistic view of the church and we
say wow. You know we have uh 25 million
members worldwide. Now what is 25
million in the context of eight or nine
billion?
>> Correct.
>> I mean sometimes I sit frustrating. How
are we going to going to finish this?
And then I remember Jonah.
>> Amen.
>> Three-day crusade, 120,000 convers,
[laughter]
>> even the animals.
So, so there is hope.
>> That's powerful, powerful preaching.
[laughter]
Praise the Lord. And it's going to be
repeated. We're the flood that's going
to come in at at the very end is going
to going to amaze and overwhelm us. And
praise God for it. again our time we
have fun during doing this program and
we love studying the word of God. Uh
hopefully you are informed and inspired
also not only to study the word of God
but to show thyself approved by deep
study. Amen. Not just surface study
because it's the deep study that will
anchor your soul in these last days.
Again our time has slipped into
eternity. Allow me in closing to with
you wish you both grace and peace
through our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ. We'll see you again soon.
Bye-bye and God bless.